[Music]
there's a player on the las vegas
aviators roster who made the olympic
team sports director chris matthews
joining us with more in studio on this
young man chris that's right who knew
about this yeah there are 25 players who
make up team usa baseball the olympic
team there and nick allen was one of
those guys in fact he was playing double
a ball in midland when he got the call
he's heading to the olympics then while
in tokyo
got the call he's being promoted from
double a to aaa he'll be landing in las
vegas how about that fresh off winning a
silver medal in tokyo he gets a call
that you're heading to vegas playing in
the games is an experience he'll never
forget and wonders if the outcome would
have been different without all the
coved restrictions
you couldn't go to any other sporting
events
and watch um any other athletes
but
i think that's that was one thing that's
changed i congratulate
tokyo for holding this
and you know they did a great job uh
because
in this these circumstances they'd be
very stressful and very hard to do but
they did a great job there they made us
feel safe and comfortable but yeah i
mean if if we would have some fans there
who knows what could have happened i
mean i know when we played japan it
would have been a packed house at the
stadium for sure
so who knows if that could have you know
swayed one thing
we will never know allen was voted as a
team's best defensive player he was
drafted with the 81st pick in the 2017
draft by the yeas he's number three
right the number three prospect we
should say in the years organization
now here he is right there driving in a
run for the aviators he wears number 12.
so that's pretty cool stuff here in las
vegas now you can watch nick tonight the
avid years hosting albuquerque at seven
o'clock